police in uganda have released athlete
julius
sekitaleko on police bond pending
further investigations
after he was controversially deported by
authorities in japan
the way lifter had traveled to the
olympics in tokyo expecting to compete
but it later emerged he had not
qualified he then reportedly went
missing
later he handed himself to the
authorities outside the japanese capital
who sent him back to uganda
this is the kampala gym where
sachitolico has trained
since he was 10.
many successful ugandan athletes come
from humble backgrounds
like this the 20-year-old weight lifter
want things to improve in his country
as athletes who live in poor conditions
many of them just like me
imagine all the years i spent
weightlifting i have nothing
that did not lower his hopes when he
traveled to tokyo
as part of uganda's national team
but just days to the games he found out
that he actually hadn't qualified for
the competition
and anomaly being investigated by the
ugandan authorities
i just picked up a few of my belongings
and i retreated to my room
i was very disappointed and close to
tears
sexually then chose to escape reportedly
with the hope of finding a job in japan
to be able to save his family from
poverty
but when the authorities tracked him
down they deported him
arriving at uganda's enteve
international airport
he was arrested this angered his mother
who had come to comfort her son without
the knowledge that the police
wanted him locked up why are you
harassing my son please let me have him
sachitolico's family had high
expectations when he traveled
to japan his pregnant wife
had thought that it would come with
financial blessings
to even afford them a new home after she
was recently evicted for failure to pay
rent
he left to decide with nothing
he thought he's going to get some money
and everything is going to be okay but
right now
everything is not ok they just started
out of the house
so us destruction is not good
at all many ugandans are empathetic
towards the family
such teleco has won more than 15 medals
for his country
in other competitions and some think
that
he deserves better treatment of all the
medals he's one for uganda is this how
government wants to appreciate him
instead of julius being arrested he
should be pardoned rehabilitated and
given another chance to nurture his
sporting talent
has now been released you may be out of
the picture
at the tokyo games but not out of
dreaming
that someday he will win an olympic
medal for his country
and to live a better life
you